speaking of scandal this year's Academy
Awards have become a target for protest
yesterday not far from the Dolby Theatre
someone placed a statue of disgraced
Hollywood producer and Oscar winner
Harvey Weinstein wearing a bathrobe and
holding an Oscar statue now it has since
been removed but beforehand the street
artist who goes by the name of plastic
Jesus said his art had a purpose with
the Oscars on Sunday you know there's
gotta be people arriving at the award
ceremony that may have covered up
Harvey's deeds there may be people there
are victims of Harvey that still haven't
spoken out the casting couch isn't the
only installation that popped up in
Hollywood playing off the
oscar-nominated film three billboards
outside Epping Missouri these three
billboards showed up Wednesday urging
stars to name names the artist
responsible Sabo
tells ET let's clean house so we can
move on we're standing here together to
say times up very very proud to be part
of this this is not going to solve a
problem but it is an international
platform meanwhile some famous women
behind the times up movement met
yesterday and say while it's tempting to
stage another demonstration on Sunday
they are standing down we are not an
award show protest group says director
Ava Duvernay the ladies wore black on
previous red carpets in a show of
solidarity we wear black to say times up
on the imbalance of power and abuse of
power but will the lady stop and talk to
Seacrest they discussed it and Duvernay
tells the LA Times it's up to the
individuals that are going to be there
to do what they're gonna do
[Music]